hello believe nation happy weekend today
I want to share with you my first three
business cards in this business I hope
you guys have some fun with it
[Music]
so behind me in this office you may have
seen before i had this wall of memories
and I've got some trading cards my first
skateboard think it did a video on the
skateboard and what it means to me and I
thought it's the other weekend we're
having some fun maybe we should take
another item off of the wall of memories
and bring in my first three business
cards I don't use business cards anymore
when I go to events I'll take some of
these business cards but I love her I'll
never ask for it and I don't I don't use
it I don't I don't like carrying around
with me um yeah I just don't use
business cards people can find me you
type in Devon Carmichael you'll find me
on email on websites whatever Facebook
YouTube whatever you'll find me and so I
used to have business cards though and i
thought i'd share the three that i have
on my wall to share this disease our
user is there interesting okay so the
very first one this is the most
embarrassing what I think the very first
one let's hold it up here we go there it
is look at that huh I had a friend of
mine who's photographer come around with
me around where my office was downtown
in that we walked around and took that
picture I used to have that goatee going
on my slogan was helping you build a
company of your dreams so that was
exciting and email a phone number back
when I had a phone number look at that
wonder what happens when you call that
now I don't know and on the back check
out the back the back were all sorts of
different resources that i felt that
entrepreneurs should be aware of so it's
entren websites market research useful
links youth programs how to register
your business and other Canadian
resources used for Canadian
entrepreneurs as most of the people i
was talking to was canadian at the time
and so yeah i have it in a protective
casing because if these don't exist
anymore and so that's that's the first
one I may be 22 in this picture
look at that and like rocking the
Versace belt and it's in the lying sleep
okay next new and I so that was a slug
in there helping you build a comfy your
dreams then I move to this look at that
huh yeah look at that sexiness there we
go so this one reads distinctive
resources for today's entrepreneur look
at that same photographer a friend of
mine actually who helped me build this
this was when I had my second office so
this was downtown when I was out of the
venture capital office and then this is
when I moved out and had my own office
downtown and then on the back of this
one I have a picture of my parents my
younger sister and my older sister and I
wrote every day we wake up to follow our
dreams and make the world a better place
for the ones that we love thank you dad
mom Stephanie Alexander and Danny for
your continuous love and support and so
I wanted to have something meaningful in
the back so the first time I had the
resources on the back and the second
time I wanted to just show some
gratitude and love for my my family on
the back that's pretty cool I think the
other people on my team that I made
business cards for we did something
similar to so that every time you hand
it in a card it was a little bit extra
gratitude and love it almost makes you
want to do cards again just because of
forget about the front forget about this
I I don't come away that this sending
the love of the back almost almost makes
me do it again I like he's get me
thinking and then the most recent one
that I was using when I still use
business cards with this this one so
this is more professional as taking
atras taking on a cruise ship look at me
in a suit and tie it is the most formal
I've been on any of these cards the back
is just information about myself this
replicates the entrepreneur trading
cards that i did so i did these
entrepreneurs that we raised a hundred
thousand dollars plus for kiva the hell
punch prayers and africa get started and
i expect with a bunch of bloggers and
people to space and ask them who your
favorite entrepreneur is and I made it
in this style so we did Steve Jobs and
seth godin and gary vaynerchuk and a
whole bunch of people so i made my own
card in that format and this actually
hurt peoples brings a little bit because
it's not the typical size of a business
card so it's a baseball card right like
this is the business card size the other
ones a baseball card size so didn't
quite fit in people's wallets or your
normal card holder or any of that stuff
by okay with that I'm okay with breakin
convention a little bit and now no
business cards so first one second one
third one it's been a lot of fun and
they stay stay up on my wall of memories
because it reminds me of that time in my
life when I was using those and what I
was going through at the time in that
yeah so i thought i'd share that with
you i'd love to know in the comments
below what you think of the cards what
was your favorite aimed do you have any
embarrassing first business card stories
or pictures that you want to share leave
it down the comments below make a video
reply if you want with your business
cards that love to see it thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you had an
amazing weekend I believe in you I hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love guys
I'll see you soon